today I'm delighted to present our
nation's highest civilian honor to a
giant of American industry
entrepreneurship and auto racing
the legendary Roger Penske Roger I want
to congratulate you on receiving the
Presidential Medal of Freedom Hybrid
1965 to run a Chevrolet dealership in
Philadelphia he rapidly Roger from
racing to business to philanthropy you
have moved from one great victory to
another you're very unique person I know
you for a long time you're a very unique
person and truly a great champion and
truly a winner no matter what you do it
turns to gold you are a legend and the
speedway and your legend and business
and your name is revered everywhere the
checkered flag flies and beyond that
Thank You mr. president
it's a wonderful honor you know it's
amazing you know many years ago my
mother and father invested in me and
told me the love and the passion of our
great country and to think that I'm
standing here today in the Oval Office
with the president the vice president
all you're here today and especially my
family to receive this wonderful award
just hard to believe that that would
happen as we all know people make a team
and people make power I really want to
thank the president for this prestigious
honor receiving the Presidential Medal
of Freedom really is something special
and to me it means more than any
business success or motorsport trophy
[Applause]
[Applause]
you